tintin dans leur nid allô allô week est
un appareil elle c'est gad elmaleh tabac
tu m'appelles des états unis est un
numéro américain américains californie
massachusetts comme ça et tout le toutim
quoi la grande ville américaine
bah je disais que je te bat chauny chat
et je suis ton travail
je suis donc clientèle je suis en
clientèle était que j'ai ouvert ma porte
et j'ai ouvert mon petit bureau
d'esthétique
je serai le french manucure mais aussi
sur toutes les défenses exactement et
région paca également ouais c'est vrai
qu'il entend pas publique
voilà ça va contre et d'amour rabah
tombe et tu tombe bien non mais tu perds
que celle ci allait parler de toi en
plus ils monnaient j'allais parler d'eux
parce que je vais montrer des extraits
du spectacle de gad elmaleh et gad et je
vous montrer ce qu'il a fait là il était
dans un show aux états unis ouais je
peux vous dire il a mis tout le monde
d'accord qui passa parce que c'est mon
frérot que je laime mais je vous montrer
des extraits aux états suivent et
maintenant tu y arrives là bas sur la
tête de ma mère
il n'y a même pas besoin de montrer
qu'on passe pour moi la fois que j'aurai
avec un poster de gad elmaleh bas landes
payor state building et masi et qui sait
qu il a un rôle de folie
on m'a dit oui baba
[Applaudissements]
ce qui fait le spectacle en anglais de
gad elmaleh
parce que je sais pas je comprends mais
c'est vrai dit baba c'est la première
fois que je comprends l'anglais dans mes
frères nombreux autres mais bon on va
passer des extraits de spectacles et si
tu veux nous rappelles tu as l'air
battait le bienvenu tu sais moi je veux
mon portable est ouvert au nom du
mouvement nature et le passé un nom mais
pas masquer tout bas il ya quelqu'un qui
a un message pour nous il ya quelques
messages sur toi à toi que tu m'as nom d
une mort d'annick match
os qu'un amour tu voulais prendre de mes
nouvelles banon va prendre de tes
nouvelles là parce qu'on va voir des
extraits de toi là ça va arriver là ça
arrive là dans comment tuer si tu dis
oui bah c'est est ce que tu m'as dit
emile effet une bassine avec des sorties
tu sais qui atténue cayla est délicat
vient la voir aujourd'hui à les
habilleurs dalmatiens la compétence car
il est chaud il sort sur médecine est
c'est un truc de ouf ça sort dans le
monde entier c'est la première fois en
première mondiale dans al mana en
allemagne en angleterre en hollande
si tu passes en hollande bah oui
ramène-moi des tulipes terre où j'ai
besoin pour bader gad elmaleh
[Applaudissements]